the jurgen experience it's a very insane
time
yeah you know why people overreact
though it's because
it's not the same for everybody like i
have a friend
who got kovid he's 37 he was clear of it
in three days
in three days he felt like [ __ ] he
couldn't smell he couldn't taste
three days later he was on zpac and
something else
and just stayed home and he got vitamin
ivs every day and then three days later
he's going on a 25-mile bike ride three
days three days he's fine i don't know
if it's a good idea to go on that bike
ride by the way
yeah but i want to see what happens so
i'm not saying anything
i hope he wears a mask yeah i want to
see if it uh makes him feel like [ __ ] if
he goes on the bike ride or if he feels
great i was talking to dl
because you know he just got diagnosed
that was really scary
and he was like no i got nothing he's
fine yeah i
said i've felt nothing the entire time
well um he coughed a little today
he had a video a little bit of video he
was hilarious he's like oh my covis is
acting out yeah yeah i saw that because
he probably smoked a joint right before
that
probably right but it was scary watching
him just slump into unconsciousness
on stage and whoever that guy is that
caught him that guy's a [ __ ] hero
that's his
road manager i think his road manager is
a [ __ ] hero because if dl
fell he would have smashed his head on
that stage and you got real problems
then
yeah because he was just sitting there
and he he slurred his words and the
audience was like what
the [ __ ] did you just say like they
couldn't understand what he said you saw
the video
i did not see the video let's see if we
can find it it's it's
i only just found out there was a video
of it like two nights ago because cedric
was at my house
dl is a [ __ ] great guy he's a great
he's a great guy i used to open for him
you know that and two no shane
23 years ago he's smart as [ __ ] he's a
really smart guy but a really good guy
too yeah
really good guy i'm really honest and
yeah and i think minded
i think uh the uh a lot of the uh
here it is right here so he's on stage
and uh i guess his road manager fella
that right that guy right there
gives him a drink of water he puts the
water down
and uh he's this doesn't have any volume
unfortunately
there it goes here it goes
we've been the coordinator so long and
we came back
uh never there remember everyone want to
get rid of
thanksgivings they were immigrants
right everybody's like what see now what
you hear that what
but now watch he just slowly starts
slumping look that guy that road manager
is a
[ __ ] hero because that guy was there
look his head still hits the bound yeah
a little bit
but the what i was worried was a stroke
because sometimes that happens to people
first of all the way they drag him off
the [ __ ] stage like hey guys
when you [ __ ] actually carry them
because they didn't even let him finish
his set though they're dragging him
though
bouncing off the i know they didn't let
him finish this just throw some water on
him
come on what was the problem for comics
we can get through this
they said like we have everything okay
and everything like yeah right you don't
have nothing out of control
yeah nothing's under control joe rogan
meets a crazy stripper
um the the the real scary thing was the
slurring of the words
yeah because he was at my house about
less than a month before that happened
[Applause]